alors on fait tourner ce film qu'est la
différence pour vous entre la vie
sentimentale de l'époque telle qu'elle
est évoquée dans le film est aujourd'hui
finalement les adolescents d'aujourd'hui
ceux d'avant à peu près les mêmes
problèmes c'est juste les tabous
peut-être qu'ils ont peu changé
là c'est la génération d'avant pilule
donc ça c'est déjà important
et puis nos sida on savait pas ce que
c'était non plus donc je pense que c'est
surtout au niveau de la sexualité que ça
a changé après après une époque qu'on a
appelé la parenthèse enchantée dans un
film avec clotilde courau qui était donc
l'époque
après la pilule et avant le sida c'est
une super idée si price qui n'a jamais
été traité au cinéma
c'est un roman de françois armanet
d'abord et puis après on lui a demandé
de l'adapter il adapté de lui-même au
cinéma et ça c'est réussi c'est son
premier film
oui ça marche bien en tous les cas pas
tout tous les gens qui l'ont vu puisque
le film sort mercredi
enfin tous les critiques voilà on
attendre et surtout des critiques de
bord très différents qui sont assez
d'accord donc on verra il faut que le
public suive
c'est ça le plus important m comptant à
- shirazi alors bon vous avez un fiancé
ont pas dire le nom à mon seul hic ici
cette émission est réputé pour sa
discrétion pas le genre d'endroit va le
dire on va l'y crise ne va pas dire qui
c'est un non non murmuré tout doucement
non mais si vous crevez d'envié terrine
n'ont varié avec des connus il est aussi
plus que cécile cassel aussi tonique
mois voilà leur confère une interview
par amour on avoue charles ordinaire
on ne bouge par le preneur ne bouge pas
pendant le génial c'est courageux si
courageux a alors allons-y interview par
amour est-ce que par amour ou seriez
prête à vous déguiser en elton john ah
oui ah oui ah oui certains de la chance
on prend beaucoup sur toi est-ce que par
amour vous seriez prêt s qui se déguise
en elton john et on avait dû continuer
pas son nom
à est-ce que par amour vous seriez prête
à arrêter de faire du cinéma
j'ai déjà quitté quelqu'un parce qu'il
m'a empêché de faire du cinéma
oulalala et c'était avant de commencer
et bah je pense que j'ai bien si
l'accord donc je pense que j'aurais du
mal à rester avec quelqu'un qui
m'empêche de faire ce qui n'est pas
nominé au club
est-ce que par un nouveau seriez prête
elle a habité s'étend à londres et à
faire la cuisine non à londres c'est sûr
et certain sens a dit l'accusé et faire
la cuisine je me débrouillerai pour
parfaire tous les sens que par amour ou
seriez prête à vous convertir à une
autre religion
j'ai failli aussi à quelle région
défilent chez vous ah bon oui est
vraiment en deux ans je disais que pour
ça je n'étais plus juive que certains
j'y suis donc oui où les miels si la
police arrête le cinéma et non il n'a
pas voulu car est il a même pas venu pu
commencer
est-ce que par amour vous seriez prête à
ne pas faire d'enfant
si je perds ma docteurs n'ont vraiment
pas par amour oui paramore par mois
est-ce que par amour vous seriez prête à
cacher quelqu'un qu'il vient de tuer oui
mais j'ai en galerie sérieux après quand
même c'est pas bien ce que tu as fait
est-ce que par amour vous seriez prête à
prendre 17 kg oui mais les hommes vous
est terrible parce que vous dites par
amendis prend 17 qui depuis a pris haïti
parce que vous êtes une jeune sur ben
oui oui mais pas question clotilde
courau est ce que pas vous seriez prête
à embrasser cent fois oui j'ai fait je
tenais cette question posée la question
chez cette salle wissang fois par amour
vous demande est-ce que par amour vous
seriez prête à accepter quelques petit 1
infidélité grèce portant mon garçon à me
dire j'ai dit chaussettes à ça je suis
josé est d'accord est-ce que par un mot
vous soyez prête à devenir son esclave
sexuelle
je ne vois pas très bien ce que ça veut
dire mais pourquoi pas j'espère c'est
que je le fais tout ce qui vous dit oui
j'ai confiance en lui je sais pas peut
pas aller trop trop loin il n'ira pas
jusqu'à me tuer donc ça dommage quand
même nom de quoi qu'il ait pas trop lent
oui d'elle oui ces mines et vous êtes
sûr il avec ma mère j'ai entendu les
excuses de merde
prochain